tying the 1718 Maple Le for the second highest
total in the past 30 years Tampa Bay scored
37 through 7 to begin the 2012 season so Steve
Eiserman after a slow start Winnipeg's team save
percentage is 29th in the league but on the power
play here back in front of the net a couple of
waack for tily and then the attempt by Al follow
it Escape in front went to the corner 30 points
or more each of the past four seasons for Pon jets
are in pass back and a good save there on Mason by
Rymer near side Schmidt moves in again back for
Peretti with plenty of room and time and a shot
and just wide on the stick side of Ryman back for
him again threw it in down low Freer scores what
a shot top shelf you know Nikolai eers can score
that's his first of the season for the native of
Denmark good Puck movement I don't know if this
hit the defenseman and went up into the top or
not but it might have hit sherat and boy oh boy
look at that shot up over the Trapper next to the
shoulder that's where you can score number4 Sam
16 minutes back turned with it rimmed it around
but the jet saw it and picked it off there's
Mory looked in front of the net they score
what a play by Mory pinching in from the blue
line and Kyle Connor buries that one and it's
two nothing right there on a platter for Connor
yeah it hit Hall and went right to Kyle Connor so
that's a huge break for Winnipeg and they take
advantage of it and Connor who we talked about
in our open makes no mistake boy he's going to
get an opportunity like that and like all for
two in the first this their third power play
continuation here how about this morrisy and
pan played over8 minutes two defenseman
for the Jets Lowry took it away from him
on the near side comes cider drops it back for
Dylan Lin with room and a shot rebound scores
Raymond
[Applause] Dylan Lin point streak continues one
in every game after the puck when and he's on his
knees juicy rebound on the back hand no mistake
there and good Raymond get tripped up look at
him that's after the goal post in overtime the
other night this whole play started really by
der brinkin on the far side he kept it alive
against the first sh along with Kyle Conor
mirrored there by cider is Shing back to what a
save what a play and what a save oh got to look at
that again back door play by shley oh my goodness
Red Wings dodged the bullet there as Kyle Connor
had it in his feet it went off the heel of his
stick and he couldn't find a job what a job he's
done
behind it goes Ras SM and rer on try big save
there pretty close that's a you know left skate
on the on the on the left goal p and bad flut on
the ground as close as the splits as you're
going to get and a good chance for Ras Mion
that'll be the fourth ball chance for the Red
Wings tonight if Dello was right on him or he
might have gone five hole unbelievable back in
the day Alex De Brink you're talking about him
almost 11 minutes of ice time and Dylan Lin
about 13 he kills penes and Alex usually does
not ball marks going T night for Boston they
alternate goal tenders will likely see Jeremy
San here's Lin a save made there kicked out
of play by halar about to stick out on that
a little pull and snap by Dylan you don't see
that too often out of him in the Deep slot he
pulls it tries to use the defenseman as a screen
and it looked like it almost did SP him a little
bit but watch him pull it snap it right next to
the defenseman's leg and then cut his [Music]
uh the brink it to Larin back for to Brink it oh
boy and save made you feel it coming that could
have gone in real easy again though you know
good scoring chance but they could be better
and huk is able to see it all again he's uh
getting it back from confer strong couldn't
one time it wanted to in a little tight now
a shot easy save haluk rebound off haluk 20
seconds to go man Advantage good recovery
Comer ballman down low Raymond slot Comer
drops back spra right in the go and huk
again Bron got a great shot wman holds in
pper across Raymond's got it strong look for a
pass in front cleared and out of the box comes
Morrison W it's all for two Detroit in the
power play thees off right in on goal drops
it back handn on rebound all Rymer sliding
stopped shely awkward but he made the save
both ends of the ice boy opened up pretty
good by nikov and a block shot goes right
back to stely just like the Conor goal
this time Rymer makes the [Applause]
stop captain of the Jets Lowry with
a feed to neita Ryder back for him
Lowry in front scores goes off Appleton
the former Spartan and in and it's 3 to
one it uh might have got off a skate
I don't know this is on side look
like that right leg is trailing y sure
enough linesman right there to make that
call yeah nicely executed
by by winipeg for sure and
go to the net like that was left there for Justin
Hall back in L and in for Fisher save made by
hel and Lowry stole it for Winnipeg empty net
for the Red Wings kept in by cider rimmed
around B bounce in front and a save made
by halabu off Raymond control you are right
on the call on Pon coach Here Comes Larin net
empty for Detroit GS to spare cider got over
to keep it in right in front of the goal and a
chance there boy two a shif or two a goal for for
Lucas Raymond took a good bounce for Detroit in
tight and another one right there off the back
fors for Raymond who has the goal tonight for
Detroit Well you certainly need
you can give hellu credit when he
was challenged he was Raymond Pon
Larin got a stick in there in came
cider strong and lift of the stick
to keep it alive by De Brink it now
cider shot into a crowd Appleton
moving one ahead with the empty
net and hit there by neita [Applause]
Ryder 62 seconds left Jets have four
on the boardings going on the
road for two now having lost
two a lot of disappointment and very
frustrated Alex to Brink it and their
point streak will end at six games coming up with
nothing here tonight as we'll send it
to Red Wings live with Larry and John